what's up everyone welcome back to the
channel for another ghost discussion
cause I'm obsessed with this show and
this cast Rebecca wasaki welcome to the
channel thank you for having me is this
actually a ladies night or is this a
casual conversation this is a casual
Halloween specific conversation but I
will put it out there the door is wide
open for a ladies night every time I'm
determined to make my way through your
entire ensemble for ladies nights
I would absolutely so okay wait so the
next time I get to see you all in person
and like the interview setting is
conducive to this my first big question
because Danielle was bringing this up to
me are you in on the competitive
Scrabble playing that's happening oh
yeah yeah well no it's no longer
happening because Danielle put a job to
it did she tell you that okay yeah she
told me it had to come to an end because
it was getting too intense yes she's the
wisest amongst us and I think it started
um we're all very verbal and really into
games there's games in the tents and
things and
um when we took our break for Christmas
last year we were I mean as sick as it
sounds because we spend every moment
together in Montreal we kind of missed
each other and so we started doing this
online Scrabble and it got really
intense really competitive and Non-Stop
and Danielle at a certain point and we
all kind of thought she was joking just
said you know what for the good of the
family y'all we need to delete this app
you need to delete this app right now
and we were thought we thought it was
drugging but then we we we did it and we
realized yeah we could have gone to a
dark place with the Scrabble I have so
many questions about this first I need
to know was this words with friends or
is there another Scrabble app that you
know it was more people yeah no I used
to play Words With Friends it's a
different one like can't remember what
it is now
um I can't remember what it is I mean
you not being able to remember what it
is is probably better off for me
this this question feels a little too
intense but but who was the best who was
the best Scrabble player uh well
Richie's a killer I'm pretty good uh
Asher got very very competitive and I'm
not saying that he would cheat but some
no I shouldn't even put that out there
because that is sacrilege in the
Scrabble community so no we there
everyone was really good and everyone
got super into it I play a lot of words
with friends with people and I I do I
assume the worst of people when I see a
word that who who is going to think of
that you are using a dictionary or a
word finder
I'm not saying that that was going on
but the desire to dominate was strong
well one day I'm gonna bring the
competitiveness back and I'm going to
show up to an in-person interview with
my Bananagrams bag and I'm going to
teach you all Bananagrams Bananagrams I
loved Bananagrams so much I haven't
played in a while
it's a it's a great great game but now
no one will play with me anymore because
like I'm pretty good at word games and I
get very intense and now my family won't
play with me anymore yeah you know what
Danielle's very good at that she brought
into the tents is Mancala have you ever
played oh wow that brings me back to
like my sleep away camp days I did play
a lot of that yeah and Richie's very
into the cribbage yeah
okay I'm gonna say a basketball hoop and
it's a whole camp-like setup again you
must come see it one one day it is the
dream Tis the dream I will at least
bring Bananagrams to add to the pile of
games
um let's talk a little bit about uh
Halloween now in particular because like
I'm a I'm a big uh horror lover this is
my time of year for Hetty if she had the
opportunity to change her outfit what do
you think she would dress up as for
Halloween
oh
maybe the very same dress in a different
color I don't know putty's Petty likes
routine she likes order she is comforted
by the cage of that uniform I think I'm
not sure you know we start to see her
let loose a little bit
and you know you notice in The
Possession episode last year when when
Hedy Woodstone lets loose she has pretty
voracious uncontrollable appetite so you
know you you'll start to see her unwind
a little bit okay okay uh the more
important question now are you dressing
your dogs up for Halloween
oh
no I'm not gonna do that I'm not going
to do that to him
I'm not going to do it
as someone who uh dresses her cat up
every single year for Halloween I think
your answer is probably the right answer
yeah yeah they don't need they don't
need any additional
fur coats they've got yeah yeah that's
when you get like a like a fun Halloween
fabric bandana or something
last year I did make three ghost
costumes for them out of
um pillowcases and they didn't enjoy it
and so I'm not going to make them do
that what do you dress your cat up at so
so this is actually Malcolm's very first
Halloween and he's named after he was
very sorry to hear about you thank you
for saying that um do we do we pave the
way to Malcolm though and I'm very
thankful for that because I had never
been a cat person before Dewey and
Malcolm is named after Ian Malcolm from
Jurassic Park so he obviously had to be
a dinosaur and uh I obviously had to
photoshop him in his dinosaur costume
into a frame of Jurassic Park so we won
this year it worked out well you have a
picture to show oh that I do I will uh I
can send it to you after it's uh it's on
my Instagram but uh you know he wasn't
uh he wasn't thrilled with the whole
idea but I got that one good photo that
uh and that's all I need that's all I
need
um again I am obsessed with horror
movies and I this is like a little
complicated I have a three-parter for
you I want your favorite horror movie
the scariest horror movie you've ever
seen and then also your horror movie
dream role whether it's you know casting
yourself in something that already
exists or maybe planning for something
exciting in the future
well I can't stop thinking and I
probably shouldn't say this the very
first movie I ever did which I don't
even know if it qualifies as a movie I
was a horror movie in which I had my
spinal fluid ritualistically drained on
the beaches of Long Island it was about
a whole like the uh I shouldn't even
talk about it because I don't even know
I doubt it's findable but I remember it
um yeah I I had to die in this very
elaborate way collapsing into the sand
after having been sacrificed it was a
whole group of like young young models
around town were being you know
sacrificed for their spinal fluids it
probably was some sort of Fountain of
Youth someone told me that I wouldn't be
able to find one of their early horror
movies recent recently and I found that
thing and I own it on DVD now no I don't
even I don't even think that that's
cool um so there's that I remember oh I
should have come more prepared because
there's a horror movie maybe it was
10 years ago was it called uh it was the
one where all the group of girls go
spelunking in the cave are you talking
about The Descent last God I loved that
movie hands down one of the best one of
the best horror movies ever made I'm not
being hyperbolic about it I have a
descent poster downstairs I'm obsessed
with that yeah I loved that movie and I
would love to do a movie like like that
but it would really scare me it would
really scare me but I would love to do
it I feel like it's only a matter of
time before they either remake The
Descent or add another installment to
that series of films did they not I have
some vague memory that they did there is
a second one yeah do you recommend it's
not as good isn't that it's good that
bears a re-watch for this Halloween
Halloween season but you know I really I
don't like being chased so ah boy I
don't like I really freak out it's the
one thing I watch football with my
husband
because all I can think about is oh all
the chasing I would just I I it bothers
me a lot you that's the easiest way to
freak me out is just to chase me I'll
just stop and turn around and say just
stop it okay yeah this is gonna be uh
good ammunition for my last game but
first I want to talk a little bit about
uh the the actual episode here which is
excellent um Halloween to the ghost of
hedy's past I don't know how you guys
keep doing it but every single episode
of this show just Delights me to no end
um first thing I wanted to ask you about
is just guest stars in general because
obviously the addition of Molly is a big
thing in this uh in this particular
episode and you know from my limited
perspective whenever someone new comes
into the cast of Ghost you seem to give
them the warmest possible welcome and I
know you've had a lot of guest uh
experience on past shows before yeah so
on those past shows is there any
particular time where you kind of looked
around and you said I love the way this
group of regulars is treating me right
now and when I'm a regular on my own
series I'm gonna do that for my guest
appearances well you know the first you
know long action show that had a life
that I was a regular on was Devious
Maids and and I remember thinking that
very clearly you know the tone is always
set from the number one on the call
sheet down right and I've like you said
guest starred on a lot of TV shows and
and it just makes all the difference in
the world I mean that that really is a
family there are hundreds of crew
members that come there every day and if
the set is a positive place in a warm
place it's your home and so I that's how
I think of it when someone comes to your
house you know you offer them tea and
ask them about themselves and you know
you want to make sure they have an
enjoyable experience and that's not put
on I mean we all happen to be very you
know nice people and um we enjoy having
people come play with us and I'm that's
something I'm really proud of that
people walk away saying like oh I'd love
to be on the show but also I've had a
really great time you know so and Hannah
Rose May let's please name Checker who
plays Molly is so stunningly beautiful
and so nice and you know despite being
incredibly Irish was a delay
it's not can't be easy to go Toe to Toe
with all of you so it always like really
impresses especially when I get to meet
someone who is who's new who I don't
know their body of work and I see them
jump into ghosts in particular and you
know like really play hardcore with all
you guys yeah yeah there's a lot of
balls up in the air and especially for
the people who come on and or play
livings that's a learning curve to
realize that you have to be part of you
know the music of the whole thing but
you can't look at us I mean and that's
we just had
um uh Laureen Newman come on who
I mean I you know I mean icon and she
exceeded expectation in every possible
way she she was magnificent and but but
even she was like oh wow again it's so
compelling you know they you want to
talk to us because you know the ghosts
are saying interesting things but yeah
that's fun to watch people negotiate I
have a very random uh ghost ability
question have you guys discussed much
why they can smell things but they can't
taste things
well you gotta give us something right
that's what I say about the washing
machine too thing too like that you
could argue that Hedy wouldn't
necessarily be moved in such a way by a
physical object but come on you gotta
give it you gotta give me that right
um I you know we're talking about car's
character Jay is keeping this whole you
know I love that he's such a nerd that
he's so into it and he ends up he ends
up providing he ends up being the hero
in a lot of the you know the the the
trouble we get up to because he has this
knowledge of all these genre films and
TV shows and things and he's able to say
like oh what they did in Ghostbusters
was you got to just go do this which
happens in this episode right yeah so
he's keeping a whole log of what you
know ghosts the ghost rules are he is
doing one heck of a job still still to
this day and I I can't imagine anyone
topping this I'm pretty sure he made the
best Jurassic Park reference that I've
ever heard in any movie or show out
there what was it
I mean he went on and on and it was like
a whole spiel about I mean basically
almost like the entire chain of events
that happened in Jurassic Park and I
asked him about it and he told me that
it was all improvised and my mind is
just blown from that which I I need to
go back and watch that again do you
remember what episode it was I forget
the specific episode it was probably
about Midway through season one yeah but
he's like explaining things to Sam and
he's trying to he's trying to change her
mentality and I'm pretty sure he had
brought up the line like the the idea of
like just because you can doesn't mean
you should kind of think it was just so
so brilliantly done
so wonderful such a great series of
character choices that he's made to you
know what it what a difficult
thing he has to do and that he's you
know not only on board but like deeply
nerds out about it and wants nothing
more than to be friends with us and
interact with us and you know I think
it's just it's a delight and it's a
delight to be around he's like I said
very good improviser he's always
throwing little like hey hey what did
you say this here or you know we're all
kind of we all do that with each other
so that's lots of fun oh I have an
improv question in a minute because I'm
very curious about a certain line that
you say in this particular episode but
before getting there you uh you brought
up the idea of the challenge of you know
someone coming in to play a living and
you know that there's the technicalities
of acting as a ghost too when you were
in the vault and doing that particular
scene is doing something like that in a
contained space with like two other
guaranteed people that can always see
everybody in play is that like the most
freeing thing in the world to just be
able to play like that and not have to
worry about the ghost rules you know
it's funny I don't even think about it I
mean I I love I love the big crazy well
what do you mean not be able to think
about the ghost rules like they're just
they're just stuck in a room you don't
have to worry about the ghost
disappearing or someone not being able
to see you it's just three people who
can actually really have a conversation
you know this is interesting because I
don't even From hedy's perspective I
don't ever think of it like that it's I
think it like heady is this is her house
she talks to whoever she wants to she
you know she ignores Jay for the most
part and
um uh yeah I love those those small
scenes those two and three person scenes
yeah I mean and you see in the scene in
the vault heady I mean it's a life or
death situation and Hedy is really just
annoyed that that she's been put in an
uncomfortable situation she's very
selfish that's one of the things that I
love so much is you know they've allowed
her to take these steps and and become a
little bit of a feminist and find some
sense of empowerment and you know social
justice and all these things but at the
same time she she's not going to change
fundamentally that she's a flawed
creature in a big way you know
so she's because she even says at the
end of the episode I've changed and she
very much has changed since day one when
we the audience first met her but I
don't know do you have any ideas in mind
in terms of what like the next level of
change can be and and is that change
necessary to her ultimately being sucked
off and if she can't change
fundamentally to that extent will she
ever get sucked off
I don't know I mean that's the question
for every single one of the ghosts
there's some some reason and you know
you start to get into that kind of
thought process this season with some of
the ghosts not necessarily me of like
well wait
do I really want to actually learn this
lesson if I really become a good person
I won't be your friend anymore because
I'll be gone and what does that mean and
you know
um
uh
yeah I
I'm not sure Hedy will ever completely
get it and that's something that's
enjoyable and that's something that
feels really human and that's where so
much of the funny lies is you know in in
in that she has a real journey this this
year if make mistaking
empowerment for power
and
um so she just doesn't ever quite get it
but she gets it enough that allows her
friends to keep you know trying so
anyway I want her to be the best
possible version of herself and I want
it for all the characters but my biggest
fear is them achieving that and then
them not being on the show anymore or
them getting sucked down I mean any
number of things can happen okay now
descend from heaven apparently so I mean
the mythology is expanding we're
referring to that as sucked down
right or no no go the going down on us
Alberta coin oh God yeah that's what it
was okay which so there there's another
question that popped into my mind after
watching this particular episode because
I know when um when she sent her husband
to hell that that was a thing that
everyone like maybe that's her power now
she's also right there when Molly gets
sucked off so is that possibly her power
and can the power work both ways
and maybe it wasn't the Seance at all
well if there's some way that she can
mistake that she's in charge she'll take
it you know but I I don't necessarily
think that her power is to banish people
to hell but she probably enjoys toying
with that idea we don't know if she has
a power yet I think the the real sad
thing would be if she is profoundly
powerless ultimately and is the only one
not to actually have a special power
that would be a fun kind of Journey to
play but
um yeah I I'm amazed that we get past
standards and practices with some of the
things that that we say and as you
mentioned there's a real juicy one at
the end of this episode
I'm going to say it because it's so
funny and I won't deliver it funny I'm
gonna do it very straight Let Me Ride
you while you get sucked off was that on
the page or did that just come up at the
moment Oh you mean did I come up with
that nope that was on the page so
important Joe Wiseman are just
brilliant and that that entire like end
how like how many times do you have to
do that how do you figure out how big to
go because yet again I mean this happens
all the time in the show the delivery
and the energy there is just at a Pitch
Perfect level oh that's very kind of you
thank you
um Katie love or Brian who's our
director and she had she did the
Halloween episode last year too and she
she always gets the episodes that are
the most complex the most heavy with all
kinds of crazy things and pyrotechnics
and she literally burned the house down
last year I burned the the pergola down
uh and so she did this one too and so
there were a whole lot of things going
on
um there was a rigging and and a a a
stunned actress being raised up into the
sky and the light coming down and we
only had couple chances to really get
that I'm glad that you think that we got
it I haven't seen it yet so
um
yeah very that was that one was very
technically challenging and of course
all the entire cast was there in the
room for that so
um yeah did I answer the question I mean
yeah sure it's great I love it it was
the heart of the question what was I
thinking honestly I don't even know I
guess just figuring out like the the
that Pitch Perfect level of like energy
and Desperation and I guess shock too
there's a lot of heady does a lot of she
she she's very contrary you know she'll
change her mind in the middle of a
sentence and she can literally you know
leap up and and and you know beg to be
sucked off and and utilize someone
else's you know train trip there and
then turn around call them peasants and
say oh you could get over it and they
will they'll get over it because they're
they don't have very high expectations
for Eddie's moral character I think yet
they still love her so
yeah that's I mean it's all about the
misdirect and the and the you know
turning on a dime kind of thing which I
get to do a lot in the show so good so
good
um I've already kept you too long if you
have another two minutes I have a game
for you okay all right so one of my
absolute favorite games to play it is a
slasher movie Survival game so we'll
paint a picture for you a a mess slasher
appears on the set of ghosts I'm gonna
give you some horror movie superlatives
and you need to tell me which cast
member like the real person not their
character best suits this descriptor
okay all right so first who is the most
likely to not realize that they're in a
horror movie and go and investigate a
strange noise and be the first one to
get killed by the slasher probably Rose
oh
okay good leader she's a great leader
she's a great protector and she would
want to go investigate okay I like how
you spun that around into a positive
thing which is positive usually usually
the answer I get is is someone who's
kind of like not paying attention and
the most oblivious and it's just like
whatever I'll go there and that's no I
see it and he would be you know the
misbided hero okay I like that
um who is the most likely to sacrifice
themselves for the others
uh probably Devin although nothing could
kill Devon
um
probably Danielle
I would also I feel like I would believe
this descriptor true of all of you
that we would sacrifice ourselves yeah
you guys are like a genuine family you
know what there actually is a plot line
later in the season that this is
reminding me of
interesting I'm gonna file that away for
later here's a less flattering one who
is the most likely to trip and fall
while running from the Killer
well if I'm in costume me for sure oh
it's not an easy one who who's likely to
trip and fall I don't know we're all
pretty athletic
why would you make people make me throw
people under the bus like this
who would be the most likely to trip and
fall none of us oh maybe Brandon I mean
bran yeah no Brandon's an athlete trip
and fall I won't do it I refuse
we all get out alive except for Rose oh
yeah okay we've established that
who is the most likely to figure
everything out first and actually give
the group a Fighting Chance of surviving
um I mean again that would also possibly
be Rose
I kind of like this picture that I'm
building right now where like rose is
the answer to every question and it's
it's a horror movie Just starring Rose
in every role wouldn't you want to see
that I can't no but I genuinely would
watch that it's a plausible answer for
actually every single one of those
um of those questions all right I'll
throw you a curveball one I I love this
because I I play this game with my
family all the time and we like try to
figure out who would survive and my
sister always says that this one is hard
she like she'll full out admit it on her
own who is the most likely at the start
to basically say like [ __ ] this it's too
scary I'm leaving and just give up
Danielle Danielle would say I just I
nullify the game yeah yeah she could do
that she would have the power to do that
all right I'll end with this one now who
is the most likely to be the one that
everybody thinks is dead that got killed
by the slasher but is actually alive and
comes back at the last possible second
to save the day
probably Asher
okay
funny too it would be funny too I feel
like I could see that as well all right
I gotta let you go I feel like you got
to get back to work you got to make more
ghosts for us all because it's the life
it makes me happy grown-ups yeah it's a
pleasure is always Perry always
congratulations I cannot wait to see
more thank you so much and happy
Halloween happy Halloween you are in
your poor cat